The Council held its monthly meeting for August yesterday.
The first item on the agenda, marked a milestone
for the district’s earthquake recovery,
as the Earthquake Infrastructure Recovery
Programme delivered its final report.
48 of the 52 projects in the programme have
been completed, with two more finishing over
the next couple of months.
The final projects will be undertaken as part
of the Kaiapoi East Regeneration Reserve.
Not only is the work now essentially completed
- it’s also come in under budget, with approximately
$400,000 remaining.
Councillors also approved public consultation
around Earthquake Prone Priority Buildings.
Under the Building (Earthquake Prone Buildings)
Amendment Act 2016, the Council must work
with community to identify earthquake buildings
that are high risk, and should be prioritised
for remediation.
Although there are very few of those buildings
left in the district following previous earthquakes,
the Council has identified a small number
of priority buildings in Rangiora & Kaiapoi,
and will be seeking the input of residents
to identify others.
The consultation will open for a month from
the 20th of August.
Finally, the Council has asked for a proposed
consultation around speed limits in the Rangiora-Woodend
Road area to be sent to the district’s four
Community Boards for review.
After the Community Boards have made recommendations, Council staff will present a revised
proposal to the Council, which is then expected to be released for public consultation.
The next Council meeting will take place on
Tuesday 4th of September.